okay uh so now we'll move on from neural
networks to social networks and uh uh
anna and ria striker will tell us about
algorithm design for social networks
focusing on diversity and unique work
great thank you thank you everyone from
for being here i'm anna i just finished
my phd at columbia and computer science
and i'm going to start my post talk in
german into being then just after this
program um so i'm excited to talk to you
about a brief overview of my work on
algorithmic design for social networks
in my work generally i focus on on
thinking about questions of diversity
and inequality and the main questions
that i've been working on so far is how
do you diagnose and mitigate algorithmic
bias to create fair efficient and useful
algorithms
thinking about how different algorithms
may affect different subpopulation in
your graphs in your networks for the
first part i've worked on mostly
recommendation systems and ranking
systems regarding search for example
for the second part of the question i've
worked on redesigning algorithms for
cases like information diffusion or
clustering
so i want to start with a small example
of what does it mean to even think about
algorithmic bias how would it affect
different
communities in the context of networks
and i want to start with this data set
that was collected by our lab by our
collaborator chris reader a few years
ago
it's a very interesting data set and i
know we've had a short discussion about
you having a data set session this is
something if you're interested in i'd
love to share it with you it may be
useful for many applications
um this is a graph data set with people
as notes as uh users on instagram and
edges whenever they link um they like or
comment on each other's photos
and there's assuming groups that we have
in this in this data set men and women
in different proportions
and the interesting part is that they
only have this organic connections to
each other so this data set was
collected before the who to follow
feature was implemented on instagram so
there's not a recommendation feature to
it it's just however people connected
naturally to each other
um there's many other features like time
stamp location um
a hashtag for which you can do a topic
analysis and so on
the first thing that we we looked at was
to say well how many connections do
people have what is the degree
distribution and how does that differ
between the two communities and first of
all it's kind of like a power law degree
distribution in general but more than
that here i'm showing in blue for the
original graphic nor the other colors
the percentage of one of the group in
this case the women
among those we agree at least x so as
the degree increases the percentage of
one of the group among those we agree at
least x goes to zero showing that one of
the groups is like essentially not
represented at the very top of the
network with people with very popular
degrees and you may think that's not a
big deal that's just like how the data
looks like of course it's not something
that we introduced in the data
but what we did here was to say well
what happens when you have
recommendations that are based on
friends of friends for example looking
at recommending people based on the
adamic other index or a random walk of
length 2.
and if you look again at the percentage
of one of the group among those with
degree at least
x-axis in green and in red you see that
the percentage of one of the groups in
this case the women drops to zero but
much faster
so there's this gap that got amplified
in a way and this is an example of what
i mean by this amplification of
inequality between the two groups and in
this case we looked at a degree because
that's a measure of social capital that
was mentioned heavily last um last week
as well and it may matter in your
ability to form new connections in the
future whether they're algorithmic or
organic
one way to explain this was to look at
um to look at graph models and we're
able to show to explain this kind of
phenomenon using preferential attachment
and homophily in a a model that also
embeds recommendation
and in doing so what we notice is that
well we know preferential attachment has
a power law degree distribution
people have shown that if you have two
communities and they're kind of
homophilic you have a power law degree
distribution but with two different
coefficients and if you do these
recommendations based on friends of
friends that difference between
coefficients would actually increase and
that's the kind of inequality that you
see being amplified or perpetuated at
the level of recommendations in this
data set and several other data sets so
there's a lot of theoretical interesting
questions that come from this kind of
analysis and and and models that don't
relate only to
the percentages of different people to
um among people with high degrees but
tell us exactly what are the mechanisms
that create this kind of effect and
homophily was a big one here it's a
necessary condition to get this kind of
difference there was a question
yesterday at nicole stock as well
regarding what happens if you have
differential homophily and that's
another very interesting also
theoretical question that that we looked
at in the context of recommendation and
ranking also actually and you get a very
interesting effect where one one of the
group is more homophilic you can
actually reverse this kind of effects
here and you're able to get a better
degree distribution or basically a group
gets way higher degrees
so um a bit short on that
what do we do with this kind of
information i want to argue for a very
quick overview of our our recent work
was that this kind of community level
information and analysis was really
helpful to think about well
how do how do you restore this kind of
like lost
um
i guess
lost parity on who gets to have a high
degree or a high um
number of connections in this case and
we did that in the context of
information diffusion in the social
influence maximization problem that we
uh we talked about last week in the in
the boot camp where the point is to
choose
um a number of people from which you see
the information during the network and
rely on them to spread it to the network
so we have to choose these
the the choice of these early adopters
is the optimization problem that we care
about
and generally we can do that by just
um having some approximation algorithms
based on centrality or greedy
however these don't use they're pretty
agnostic to communities they do pretty
well in practice but
one recent concern is that
people have shown that well if you have
different communities the kind of bias
that you see in the degree distribution
will be also perpetuated at other kind
of centralities and you end up with one
of the groups being left out of the
information loop and that's a kind of
issue where where we're thinking about
solving and using the information that i
showed you before
so in doing that we can think about um
adding back
the the
this lost
parity between the two groups here red
and blue as a constraint and if we add
it as a constraint in the outreach of
our optimization function
you end up with a solution that gets you
a trade-off between
being fair and being efficient it
doesn't reach as many people as you
would otherwise if you don't think about
communities at all
what we're doing with this kind of
network models and results that i showed
you before is that well you can actually
overcome that and if you add it as a
constraint at the at the
early adopter set and using the kind of
network models particularly homophobia
is an important part of this you can use
this to estimate the size of your
campaign and to show that there are many
conditions in which
being fair being diverse can actually
help you being more efficient in
optimizing your outreach it gets you
many more people than before
um this is i guess conceptually related
to what also nicole was talking about
yesterday in the case of the labor
markets when you add more diversity in
your referrals
you're able to get more people active
into the labor market and if you don't
you end up with fewer people
because the same
the the people who are in a majority
group or advantage group will just
recommend each other but i recommend the
same people
so how would that look like well the the
key parameter here is to look at the
size of the seed set and the different
parameters we have here whether it's
like how big is the minority how
homophilic is the network this is just
one example of a particular network
models generated from preferential
attachment with homophily is to show
that well agnostic meaning that
you don't look at communities
in that case in this kind of case set of
parameters you would do better by being
agnostic using centrality metrics or
greedy algorithm than being fair being
fair i'm just using diversity and parity
as two different heuristics that we were
using to satisfy the constraint that i
showed you before and when you get to a
high enough number of seeds that's where
being fair either through diversity or
parity um
will get you a better outreach so these
colors basically represent you who gets
you the better outreach when are you
able to be more efficient
and that's very related to um the work
of amin
uh saber who was talking about it last
last week just a few seeds more
in which they show that well if you add
just a little few more seeds in your
information diffusion case but randomly
you're able to reach more people overall
than you would otherwise by optimizing
the problem itself
and the reason for that is that well
you're getting to parts of the network
that you wouldn't get otherwise um
and in this case
by adding more diversity constraints
you're getting to a part of the network
that is actually has lower centrality
but you actually didn't reach it overall
very well and this doesn't happen just
with centrality metrics happens with
with 3d algorithms too
but
it's much easier to show it in theory
for
centrality metrics so i want to end here
and and just discuss very quickly open
directions because
um i think some of them we've discussed
and maybe some of them will be topics of
the reading groups and i'm happy to talk
about any of this some of them i've
started to think about but some of them
i have not
um the first one being generalizing
beyond particular parametric network
models and thinking about what specific
properties can cause this kind of
difference between groups to be
projected onto different embeddings a
particular application of that is that
on ranking that i'm currently working on
and thinking about for example pagerank
using uses particular spectral
embeddings of the network data to do so
and how does that reflect on different
communities
second how can we figure out that it's a
particular algorithm that causes bias or
it's something else happening
um the the reason this this instagram
data was particularly helpful was
because we it was a graph devoid of any
recommendation it was collected before
any recommended systems were implemented
so we can see whenever you simulate one
you can see what's the effect of that
particular recommendation algorithm it
would be great to get this data after
recommendation algorithms were actually
implemented it was much harder to get it
later on after they were actually
implemented but it's nevertheless
interesting to look at
i'm also looking at feedback loops and
long-term effects thinking about
how do we um
how what has happened in in as the
network evolves a lot of this analysis
that i've shown you and a lot of the
proofs are based on the um
on on a model of network evolution that
uh relates to methods we've talked about
last week as well i'm also interested in
how do people
evolve jointly with a particular
algorithm and i know people here work on
that particularly
hara and nika as well
um how do we think about multiple
objectives and fairness beyond the
predict being a constraint sometimes
adding it as a constraint leads to this
trade-offs but sometimes as we saw here
it doesn't have to do that
and generally thinking about
interdisciplinary stuff that i don't
have to talk about as we all come from
different backgrounds here but i'll end
here you think we're on time
so thank you i can take questions now
thank you very much wonderful talk i
have a question on
on your very first thing where you
started with the degrees and then looked
at something like page rank or other
recommendation algorithms which sort of
look out for further in the network
and
you are arguing that this means that
algorithm is
amplifying bias
um
but i wonder whether i mean if i just
took that as a social network i have no
algorithm and people do recommendations
they act sort of by you don't just look
at the degrees right you may sort of
look at you look at people with high
degrees but then you look what kinds of
friends they have and are their friends
influential and people like duncan what
studied if you look how
sort of um
viral tweet spread or so it's actually
not the first note which matters with
this high degree but actually the notes
that degrees further down so one could
argue that actually these other measures
just tell you that your social network
is even more biased than you thought and
your algorithm just teases it out and if
you only look at degrees you don't even
realize how biased your social society
is
yeah yeah that's a good point that's
something that's like hidden in the
average by the way if you look at
average degree you would never see this
kind of difference in effects but you
would see it when you look at the tail
and the tail i'm guessing
you're saying that it's something that
will it
will create this amplification or will
show this amplification in the case of
recommendation what happens actually is
you end up with more polarized groups
and it's not done in itself that are
more
oralized but it's the fact that the
people who have very high degree are are
entering this rich get richer effect
that gets even more amplified yeah
good question
anyone else question
thanks let me talk